[Music]
thank you
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
program I'd like to know
our q a program that airs once a week
we've often thought about extending the
half hour to an hour but we haven't been
able to do that yet we get more
questions than what we're able to answer
quickly so if you sent us a question be
patient because it will be answered keep
tuning into the program but we have a
pile of questions and we take them in
the order in which we receive them I
want to give you the email address where
you can send us your questions you'll
see it on the screen TV at some tv.org
once again TV at some tv.org send us
your questions we'll put them in order
and we'll do the research and answer
them in so far as possible I have with
me Pastor David Salazar uh Pastor
Salazar is in charge of our uh some TV
Latino he's the coordinator of
everything having to do with the Spanish
work and he does many other things like
you can see here uh he's answering
questions on our English program
absolutely but he's a man of many
talents he's also a contractor has done
a lot of help in that area for us too so
we actually get two for the price of one
praise the Lord thank you for being with
us Pastor Salazar thank you Pastor Ward
for allowing me to be part of your group
your team the ministry is a blessing for
me to enjoy and spend time with you here
in this program as well praise the Lord
uh we want to have a word of prayer
absolutely never should we open God's
word without prayer so would you please
pray for us absolutely let's let's pray
Heavenly Father Lord as we come to you
to seek your Holy Spirit to seek Your
Grace we pray that you will help us to
receive your word and your hearts so as
we speak and we answer the questions
that our friends have sent may not be
our words but your words the ones that
really come through we pray that you
will be with us and again May the
message and the answers be those that
are listeners those that are watching
maybe looking forward to receive I pray
all these in Jesus name amen amen
all right we have um two questions by a
certain individual who has not given us
the location where they live
I'm not going to read the name but uh
let's go through these questions and see
what light we can provide
um the
email says this I have a few questions I
have been reading
but I'm getting confused somehow
and then puts in parentheses information
overload please help me then comes
question number one right in Matthew 24
when Jesus says just as in the days of
Noah
so shall be the coming of
is that referring to the second coming
to
if yes how does it tie in with the last
great deception of Satan appearing as an
angel of Light is this literal just
wondering if life really would be normal
during that deception so the question
has to do with with what the world will
be like during the time that is referred
to in Matthew chapter 24 and probably we
should just go ahead and read Matthew 24
37-39 correct so that we have the
passage that he's referring to and it
says there in chapter 24 Matthew verse
and new naught until the flood came
speaking of those people that were in
the days of Noah I shall let me read 30.
yeah 37 37 78 39 all right through 39.
but as the days of Noah where social
also the coming of the sun of man be for
as in the days that were before the
flood they were eating and drinking
marrying and giving in marriage until
the day that Noah entered into the ark
and knew not until the flood came and
took them all away social also the
coming of the son of man be
now there's something very important in
these verses that could be missed if
we're not careful in our reading
uh you'll notice two points of time in
these verses
uh it says in verse 38 for in the days
before the flood they were eating and
drinking and marrying and giving in
marriage until the day that Noah entered
the Ark that's the first point point
time time and then it says and they did
not know
obviously those outside the yard of
course they did not know what didn't
they know they did not know until the
flood came and took them all away in
other words they did not know during
that period so between the closing of
the door which was seven days and when
the flood came they did not know that
they were lost so there's the point is
that there's a period between the close
of the door probation and the second
coming of Christ correct and in between
uh the faith of Noah is severely tested
according to the spirit of Prophecy
absolutely and those outside the ark
became more and more daring each day and
so that represents the time of trouble
between the Clause of Probation and the
second coming of Christ and so the
question is is this referring to the
second coming
um well it's referring to two events of
course a probation
actually the time of trouble in between
and the second coming of Christ correct
now where does the where does the
impersonation of Christ coming by Satan
take place and that's the question and
that's a good question Pastor because as
we mentioned you know there's these two
periods that are represented in the days
of Noah because of Probation and then
that period of testing trial the time of
travel and then Christ's second coming
in the last part so the question is when
does the appearing of Satan as an angel
of Light as it mentions in second
Corinthians 11 14 that Satan can also
represent or turn into an age of a light
uh I think that is important that you
know he asks the question you know if
life really would be you know normal
when this deception is happening when
the close probation ends there is this
period where there people are going to
continue to live according to their own
lifestyle business as usually we will
but they're going to be enough evidences
or enough issues going on around in the
world that are going to give the
indication that something is happening
people are not going to be necessarily
at ease at peace the trials are gonna
come upon the world plagues maybe you
know many things that can happen into
the world and so Satan is trying to
deceive those that are still holding on
to the truth
the main thing about this deception of
Satan and I guess where we can actually
plant it in the timeline it's based on
what the purpose of that is you know
what is he trying to do
um I can reference per prophecy because
we don't really have uh in specific in
the Bible doesn't say when he'll come
but his Spirit prophecy does give us a
very clear uh picture on when that will
happen I can read this in the book
Maranatha chapter verse or page
275 76 and it says as the crowning act
in the great drama of deception Satan
himself will personate Christ
then he says
he the great the great receiver will
make it appear that Christ has come in
different parts of the earth Satan will
manifest himself among men as a majestic
being of dazzling brightness resembling
the descriptions of the Son of God given
by John in the revelation
they Glory that surrounds him is
unsurpassed by anything that mortal eyes
have yet beheld the shadow of Triumph
rings out upon the air Christ has come
Christ has come the people they must the
people prostrate themselves in adoration
before him while he lifts up his hands
and pronounces a blessing upon them as
Christ blessed his disciples when he was
upon the Earth his voice is soft and
subdued Yet full of Melody in gentle
compassionate tones he presents some of
the same gracious Heavenly truths which
the savior uttered he heals the disease
of the people the seasons of the people
and then in his assumed character of
Christ he claims to have changed the
Sabbath to Sunday and commands all to
hollow the day which he has blessed he
declares that those who persist in
keeping holy the seventh day are
blaspheming his name by refusing to
listen to his angels to his angels sent
to them with the light and Truth this is
the strong almost over mastering
delusion so the delusion happens
in this time of of of the history of the
earth that
I believe or according to what we see
here is the crowning Act of deception
the last Act of deception of Satan to
the world and to those that are holding
still to the truth of the word of God
through the truth of his his
Commandments and so it would probably
happens or has to happen after
everything else has been done to deceive
the world this is the last deception
that he's trying to do to those that are
still holding on to the truth so it has
to be after that likely close the
probation from what we see in in the
spirit prophecy yeah
24 is in chronological order some people
argue against that idea and they've sent
me emails but then I've answered back
and I've proved that Matthew 24 is in
chronological order everything is
happening one event after another which
is indicated by the word then
you know it then is used eight times in
the passage yes and each time it's used
it refers to something that happens
after something has something else has
happened and in Matthew 24 verse 21 it
says for then there will be Great
Tribulation
that's the great time of trouble such as
has not been since the beginning of the
world until this time no nor shall ever
be that's the great time of trouble
um and that says those if those days
were not short no flesh would be saved
but for the elect's sake those days
shall be shortened then notice this is
they're in the Great Tribulation then if
anyone says to you look here's the
Christ or there do not believe it no
yeah it makes sense who is Satan's Focus
um who does he want to deceive at this
point
he doesn't want to deceive the world the
world's already deceived yeah who has
not allowed themselves to be deceived at
this point those that are faithful they
elect and that's the reason why the
that's the reason why in verse 23 and 24
it says then if anyone says to you look
here is the Christ or there do not
believe it for Christ false Christ and
false prophets will rise and show great
signs and wonders to receive and here's
the target if possible even the elect
he's deceived all the world at this
point
but
one group The Remnant I I think you have
a quotation there that that I mentioned
as we were preparing for this program
about uh
that small group yes Pastor it's in the
book of great controversy page 618 and
the quote says speaking of of Satan he
numbers the world as his subjects but
the little company who keep the
Commandments of God are resisting his
Supremacy if he could blot them from the
earth his Triumph would be complete okay
so he has all the world on his side
but there's one group that hasn't given
in the elect absolutely and that's
during the time of trouble exactly and
so the counterfeit second Covenant of
Christ by Satan
has the intent purpose in in the
intention right of leading the elect to
follow the whole world in its deception
um you know the purpose of the of the uh
impersonation of Christ's second coming
by Satan is not to deceive the world
because at this point the world is all
deceived already by the way if anyone is
interested at our last Summit uh
actually uh yeah our last Summit October
of last year
uh we did a series called behold I send
you Elijah and in those study notes that
I prepared I show Beyond any doubt that
uh the counterfeit second coming by
Christ by Satan of Christ takes place
during the time of trouble after the
close of probation because there's a
theory going around that the purpose of
Satan's impersonation of Christ is to
convince the whole world and unite
Muslims and Jews and you know Buddhists
and all the different religions under
Satan's camp but when the counterfeit
coming takes place
everybody's case has already been
decided it's already too late so you can
get this these study notes at secrets on
Shield behold I send you Elijah is the
name of the series amen for that
there's a second part uh pastor about
the question that is friend sends
and it says
um in GC it says spiritualism will more
closely imitate the Christianity of that
of the day in what we are seeing these
days spiritual Revival feelings and
contemporary worship music the way
that's been made is that the way that
it's made as youth
this is the religion taking over us
please share more light a light to know
so okay so basically uh the concern that
this person has
is uh what's going on in the religious
world with people depending on signs and
wonders
um feelings contemporary Christian music
and things like that
um you know and the question is uh is
that happening well we know that it's
happening it's not on the outside but
inside The Seventh-Day Adventist Church
and the concern appears to be the youth
yes uh as youths this is the religion
taking over us so the person who's
writing this question is a young person
I would recommend
that everyone who is watching this
program read a chapter in great
controversy titled modern revivals
powerful chapter on how the Christian
world is going to appear to experience a
tremendous spiritual Revival when it's
the work not of God's spirit but the
work of another Spirit maybe I can just
read a couple of statements here
um you know it's page 463 and 464 of
great controversy Ellen White wrote
popular revivals are too often carried
by appeals to the imagination by
exciting the emotions by gratifying the
love for that what is new and startling
converts thus gained have little desire
to listen to Bible truth little interest
in the testimony of prophets and
apostles unless a religious service has
something of a sensational character it
has no attractions for them
a message which appeals to the
unimpassioned reason awakens no response
the plain warnings of God's word
relating directly to their Eternal
interests are unheeded
and so people today want religious
services that are exciting that excite
the emotions you know I want to jump in
church I want to roll in the aisles I
want to say Amen in Hallelujah I want to
exhibit emotions now there should be
emotion in our worship to the Lord the
angels in heaven sing with great
enthusiasm however trying to imitate the
world and bring it into the church and
worship as the world would
that's where the problem is and you know
Pastor has also we have seen like you
mentioned within sadly within even our
own church many of these same movements
same ideas creeping into the
worship experience where we push the
concepts of uh meditation and not
necessarily that you know nothing wrong
with meditating upon God's word you know
you've failed your mind with the God's
wordness you think about it but notation
is usually in practices that are about
emptying your mind feeling you know with
with this sense of
contemplative prayer and that kind of
thing that is really dangerous there is
you know that the enemy knows how to
deceive through emotions through
feelings through what we see the world
does we try to imitate in the church and
like as the brother mentions you know
that this is happening right now it's
one of the ways that the enemy is
bringing spiritualism in the church uh
not only that a lot of the ideas that
are being portrayed through medium you
know through the media and through
whether we read what we see it's it's
really going or taking us away from the
word of God you know as if we spend more
time listening
and hearing what men says instead of
what the word of God says the enemy will
deceive us eventually I think that the
only
security for us is to remember that
Christ says by the fruit you shall know
them in other words we need to make sure
that we don't follow anyone you know
that is not living according to the
light of the truth of the word of the
word of God and that we should really
look at the lives of some of these
individuals that I believe are pushing
these agendas Without Really living the
light or living like Christ did yeah I
wrote a book uh several years ago which
is still very very much I proposed to
this time yes uh the name of the book is
worship at Satan's throne and their
ideal with many of these worship issues
in the end time and I would recommend
those who are watching the program to uh
to get a copy of worship at Satan's
Throne because it actually deals with
the problem and what the solution to the
problem would be for example uh you know
the church many times assimilates
culture yes but the church is to be
counter-cultural you know the the early
church you read the chapter uh on
persecution in the early centuries in
great controversy Ellen White says that
the piety of the early church
uh infused the world at that time with
Terror
because because they rebuke sin and they
were so different than the world but
even in the Adventist Church today you
have uh different kinds of uh secular
music uh they put Sacred words to the
music you know like in Spanish Merengue
yeah and uh and you know many other
different uh Rock a lot of jazz whatever
Jazz you know they put all these these
uh styles of music that were actually
created for the world they were created
for the dance floor absolutely and
they're taken in
and they put Sacred words to them and
they say that this is Sacred Music uh
you know the same happened at the
Indiana camp meeting in 1900 and but the
but you can imagine that what happened
in 1900 was quite tame what they see
today comparing to compared to the rock
music and everything that is used in in
Christian churches and even in
Seventh-day Adventist churches today and
there's something you know a young
person recently we were actually
um
we went together to Costa Rica and he
mentioned to me how he had come to this
to the states and he went to a church
that was very modern he said you know
and he was telling me Pastor I really
enjoyed the service because it was a
live you know a very very down to earth
you know a lot of jokes a lot of you
know I didn't feel like they were really
uh judging me blah blah blah Good
entertainment good entertainment but
then you know I I asked him you know he
was sharing with me all these things
about his experience and and then I
asked him you know well so how is your
life you're not just asking the question
after he's telling me how he values that
type of worship and he said how's your
life really how how my my life is a
disaster he said my life's a disaster
you know I was like what happened what
do you mean well I don't have my wife
she's not with me and you know blah blah
blah and he just opened up and I was
like do you see why I mean the problem
is that a lot of this type of worship of
this type of experiences they failure
that moment of you know excitement of of
some sort of Joy I guess you know
happiness whatever it is but it's not
true it's not lasting and it does not
transform the heart because it's empty
they you you basically live as you you
came in or actually worse you were you
live in a worse State uh of deception so
I believe this is what is you know
coming into the people today and a lot
of young people have been deceived
because they feel happy excitement they
feel they're not being judged because
they can act or do whatever they want
but at the end of the day is not
transforming in their lives and they
cannot even cope with what being you
know responsible in the home or being
faithful to their wives or you know that
kind of thing uh is is because of the
fact that they're not being taught from
what can truly change a young man's way
you know and clean their their path
which is the word of God yeah so uh it's
kind of like uh when you train children
uh to eat cookies and cake and ice cream
and then you want to teach them to eat
carrots and to eat lettuce yes and
Brussels sprouts and broccoli yes they
say oh boring this is terrible why why
do they think it's terrible it's because
they've accustomed their palate to
things that are not healthy exactly and
uh and the same is true with this
contemporary Christian music it becomes
kind of like a psychological spiritual
drug exactly that you know you get the
high when you're in the worship service
you get real excited and then when you
go out and you don't have any more of
that you're worse than when you came in
like you were saying and so God wants to
have God wants to appeal to our minds in
the worship service he wants us to be
instructed you know I remember a few
years ago I was invited to speak at a
church here in our conference and you
know I arrived early at 10 30 because I
figured that the worship service would
begin at 11 right and so I you know at
11 o'clock the praise team came out and
they sang
and sang
and saying and sang
for an hour wow and so at noon the
pastor says Esther now you have 15
minutes for the sermon hmm
you know the center
of the worship service is the sermon the
word of God that's why you know you have
three three different kinds of stages
you have the stage of the Roman Catholic
Church which the altar is at the center
because the mass is Central to the Roman
Catholic church right then you have
simply a stage that's the entertainment
model right and then you have the pulpit
in the center because the preaching of
the word is Central
and that's the reason why in Advent
churches you have the pulpit although
many churches these days don't even have
a pool they just basically have a big
stage where where they have dramas and
many other different things that are
that are entertaining but they don't
really instruct and they don't teach any
concept that is based on scripture
absolutely and this is why you know
we're seeing a departure from the word
of God from The Sound Doctrine from The
Sound Doctrine into the you know doctors
of demons which is appealing to the
heart appealing to the carnal mind to
the carnal heart but it does not
really feed and help the person grow
spiritually into the likeness of Christ
into the likeness of his character and
to have that victory over their sins so
it is really the the consequence of
these deception that Satan is doing in
the last days for sure and the bottom
line is that if we enjoy that kind of
music here
the Heavenly music is totally different
I can assure you that it's nothing like
the Rock and Jazz and and meringue and
all these things that are that are
mingled in in the worship service today
those those are not created by the Lord
that's not Heavenly music and so if you
get to heaven uh you know and uh you
hear the Heavenly music you say boring
because because you've accustomed
yourself to that kind of music it's on
Earth that we need to learn the
lifestyle of Heaven because God is not
going to change our tastes on our way to
heaven absolutely those tastes have to
be changed by the power of the Holy
Spirit here on this Earth here in our
Earthly life absolutely and this is why
it's so important that we go back to the
word of God we teach our children or
young people that it's you know the way
that they can change their lives to
improve their lives to be you know fix
their relationships fix their issues is
not by you you know having an experience
that is only sensorial but to truly come
to the word of God as it says you know
in in Psalms 119 9 and 10 wherewithal
shall a man a young man cleanse his way
by taking heat there to according to Thy
word and with my whole heart have I saw
thee or let me not Wander from my thy
commandments so you see that it is truly
seeking to know the word of God to
understand time with Christ to make it
the center of our of our service of our
worship service that we will have a
change a cleansing of the way of a young
man amen amen praise the Lord
well folks time has flown by and we're
very near the end of our program we hope
that it's been a blessing to you send us
your questions please once again the
address TV at some tv.org you'll see it
on the screen we hope to see you next
time in this q a program send us your
questions please God bless you see you
next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]